Cesar Garcia and his wife Claudia have lived
in this home
in the desert town of Coachella, California
for more than 13 years.
They’ve raised three kids there, and Claudia
runs an at-home daycare out of the house.
But three years ago, they made a mistake that
could cost them their home and livelihood:
when converting their back porch into a TV
room,
they neglected to get a building permit from
the city.
The person I hired you know they do a quote,
only with no permit from the city of Coachella.
Garcia ignored early warnings from the city.
Then a team of inspectors showed up unannounced.
He pleaded guilty in court, paid a $900 fine,
and demolished the structure as ordered by
the judge.
Then he got the proper permit before rebuilding
and upgrading it into a room for the daycare.
He thought the issue was resolved.
But six months later a bill arrived...for
$26,000.
As the local newspaper the Desert Sun first
reported,
the city of Coachella is holding Garcia responsible
for paying the cost of his own prosecution.
The city had hired the private law firm Silver
& Wright.
to prosecute Garcia,
The firm promised the city that its work would
be ““cost neutral or even revenue producing.”
Garcia, who works as a grocery store manager
about an hour and half from his home,
isn’t the only building code violator to
receive an unexpected bill.
Six months after Ramona Morales paid a $250
fine
because one of her tenants was illegally housing
chickens,
Silver and Wright invoiced her for $5,600.
A woman in the neighboring town of Indio
who was cited for putting up illegal Halloween
decorations was charged $2,600.
And another family received a bill for $18,500
after pleading guilty to having a broken garage
door and overgrown lawn.
As of November 2017,
Silver & Wright had collected more than $122,000
in code enforcement fees
from dozens of residents in an area in which
the median annual household income
is about $36,000.
After Garcia received his bill, he appealed.
That drove his bill up another five grand.
Since Garcia couldn’t afford to pay $21,000
in prosecutor’s fees within a month,
the city put a lein on his house.
It’s like, “You’re going to lose your
house because you’re not paying 21,000.”
This is my house.
This is where we live, this is where we feel safety here.
Silver & Wright has a business model that's
premised on cost recovery.
They go around to these cities and they say,
“hey, we can get you 90 percent of your
fees or 100 percent of your fees back.”
Jeffrey Redfern is an attorney with the nonprofit
Institute for Justice,
which has filed a class action lawsuit on
behalf of Garcia and others
charged with the cost of their own prosecution.
This is appealing to the cities because they
figured,
“hey, if they can do this work for free,
that's great.”
The problem is that once the law firm took
over,
they have an incentive to prosecute cases
in a complicated and expensive manner.
So as to drive up the fees that they can collect
from the defendants.
Callahan and Blaine is known and respected
as one of the leading insurance law firms in the nation.
Attorney Edward Sousalik is representing Silver
& Wright in the lawsuit.
When situations like this arise, it's the
taxpayers of the city who have to pay for this.
it's absolutely a fair, outcome, because otherwise
who pays that $26,000?
It's the good citizens of the city.
The lawsuit claims that the financial arrangement
violates both the Due Process clause of the
14th Amendment to the U.S. Constitution,
and the California state constitution,
which guarantee the right to a neutral prosecutor
without financial or personal stake in the case.
Whether we're talking about civil asset forfeiture
or fines and fees or,
you know, this kind of outsourcing to a private
law firm: It's all really the same thing.
We call it policing for profit.
It's turning the criminal justice system into
a tool for raising revenue
That is a naive and false description.
This is a city attorney.
Silver & Wright working to prosecute laws
for the city.
They prosecuted over 150 people for Code Violations,
nuisance abatement, nuisance abatement.
They made the city of safe and healthy place
to live.
Garcia and the other plaintiffs allege that
Silver & Wright waited six months before billing them
because after six months, they were no longer
allowed to withdraw their guilty pleas,
which limits their ability to protest the
fees.
Is that an intentional strategy on behalf
of Silver and Wright?
Absolutely not.
Was he ever informed when he was pleading
guilty
that he was going to have to pay tens of thousands
of dollars of legal fees
for his own prosecution?
Well, it is certainly my understanding that
the people, when they plead guilty,
they have the sense that they have this knowledge
and we'll depose him thoroughly on this issue.
Any criminal defendant is presumed that they
know the law.
I mean it's not incumbent upon the police
or the judge or the prosecutor or the city
to tell a criminal defendant what the laws
are.
So what does the law say about charging plaintiffs
for their own prosecution?
Garcia and the other plaintiffs allege
that Silver and Wright aggressively pushed
city officials to change the law.
Before Silver and Wright were hired
there wasn't an ordinance on the books allowing
for cost recovery in these nuisance cases.
The city put these ordinances on the books
because silver and right ask them to do so.
One partner at Silver and Wright
is also a vice president of the California
Association of Code Enforcement Officers,
a lobbying organization that works on this
issue,
helping municipalities rewrite their administrative
codes.
Is that a conflict of interest?
Well, first off, they don't profit from the
prosecution and the laws.
Okay.
They are, they are city attorneys who work
for the cities.
And they’re paid for that work, correct?
They do many, many different tasks and responsibilities
for these cities there.
It's called the city attorney.
You handle many different functions and you're
paid by the hour.
In some ways we have a perfect storm for abuse
right now.
We have huge number of very vague laws, lots
of them criminal.
Prosecutors who have almost total discretion
to decide how to enforce these laws.
They can go after almost anyone they want.
If they're really motivated, they could find
things wrong with my house or your house.
You have the people with that discretion over
very vague, broad laws
who have an interest in getting your money.
At the very least, those people should be
neutral.
Outrage over Garcia’s story led to the passage
of a new law in California
prohibiting cities from charging defendants
for their own criminal prosecution.
But it doesn’t retroactively absolve Garcia
of his debt.
And the lawsuit is also moving forward to
set a legal precedent
that will make other state courts less likely
to tolerate this practice.
If we win this case, I think it will go a
long way
towards establishing standards of prosecutorial
neutrality.
The people who started writing these codes
never imagined that they would be giving discretion
to enforce them
to people who would then make money off of
them.
As for Garcia, he says the entire ordeal has
put his family’s life on hold.
I still worry about losing it because this
stuff is not done, it's, you know,
we are still thinking about, you know, those
$31,000.